[Musik]
kommen sie alle wollen auf und davon
die bündner sabrina und markus blum mit
tochter amira so von das einfache leben
in der kanadischen wildnis vom zürcher
oberland nach kambodscha monika lehnert
und peter kruse erfüllen sich den traum
vom eigenen kleinen gasthaus carolin
schneider und daniel schafer aus dem
kanton bern ziehen mit ihren stücken
hunden nach schweden wo sie eine
campinganlage führen
[Musik]
es gibt etwas zu feiern auf der
campinganlage sancho baden
[Musik]
ein gast hat geburtstag und zudem ist
heute der längste tag des jahres in
schweden wird dann der mit sommer
gefeiert
das wichtigste fest gleich nach
weihnachten anstatt eines tannenbaums
steht jedoch die mittsommer stange im
zentrum ein mit blättern geschmücktes
holzkreuz
doch nicht allen ist zum feiern zumute
mit auswanderer rolf kaiser hat
beschlossen mit seiner familie die
campinganlage zu verlassen
das ist für mich
danke danke sich mit sicherheit große
fertig werden wird der verbringen
vorbei sind die unbeschwerten zeiten in
der küche in der letzten folge brannte
sich die trennung bereits an daniel
schaaf verbaute die hundezwinger im
alleingang und carolin schneider musste
für rolf in der küche einspringen
in kambodscha war das gasthaus voll
gebucht
viele gäste bedeuteten stress für die
auswanderer ein problem für monika
lehnert in dieser abgelegenen blockhütte
verbrachte die familie nun den winter
erstes gold bevor sie für die geburt
ihres zweiten kindes in die sichere
zivilisation fliegen wollen
[Musik]
manchmal hilft einem das verrichten von
einfachen arbeiten seine gedanken zu
ordnen
daniel schafer beschäftigte abgaben von
geschäftspartner rolf mit der zeit
wurden die vorstellungen die differenzen
zwischen den auswanderern zu groß es kam
zum bruch woche eröffnet die richtige
situation ist yoga wohnsituationen draus
und ja im moment ist natürlich von ort
fahrzeugen ausgerückt diesem moment
dies sorgt für saubere zivilisierten was
bedeutet das überhaupt was bedeutet es
für sein genre als bedeutungslos riva
del garda
doch es bleibt keine zeit um
innezuhalten
die campinganlage ist so gut gebucht
genossen die gäste sind hier um den mit
summer zu feiern das fest der
sommersonnenwende traditionell mit tanz
gesang und plausch wettkämpfen die säcke
für das sackhüpfen muss karin schneider
im wohnhaus noch schnell zusammen hier
auch ihre gedanken kreisen darum dass
rolf mit frau silvia tochter lena den
sanji garden verlässt zwei private
gründe war dass sie das machen das tut
das tut weh das tut weh das finde ich
sehr sehr schaut wirklich im moment ist
es halt einfach hintergrund beruft
andere geschafft spezifika und
angeschafft und daher im moment nicht
stürzt mit auxerre wichtig dass man es
gab einen richtigen emotional brock der
hauptmieter später aber dass auch immer
ruhig und
für was passt und ja wie denn das wird
wieder ganz weit entwickeln
sommer es ist viel für carolin und
daniel das fest und die sorgen um rolle
sie sind angespannt
[Musik]
nach einem winter in der wildnis ist
sabrina bluhm zurück in der zivilisation
sie wohnt in diesem kleinen holzhaus in
der umgebung der stadt prince george
zusammen mit mann markus und tochter
amira und da ist noch jemand vor kurzem
hat der neueste spross der familie
blumen das licht der welt erblickt
lärmempfindlich scheint das baby nicht
zu sein
[Musik]
die zeit hier in prince george ist wie
ein mutterschaftsurlaub für die ganze
familie
denn winter verbrachten sie vollkommen
abgeschieden anna kathi dass sie dort
trafen sie vorbereitungen für ihre
pferde touren die sie im sommer anbieten
möchten
sabrina war in dieser zeit hochschwanger
es war immer klar dass sie in einem
spital gewähren wollte als der termin
näher kam wartete sabrina auf die beste
gelegenheit um nach prince george zu
fliegen
der abschied vom wilden leben kann dann
aber doch überraschend an ihrer flug-
damals mit mutter mit markus wollte
wenig später nachreisen mit ski und
schnee darf
doch das wetter spielte ihm einen
streich um ein haar hätte er die geburt
verpasst
nur drei tage vor der niederkunft
schaffte er es doch noch nach prince
george
[Musik]
stürmische zeiten in kambodscha der
monsun könntet regen an
monika lehnert bereit sich alles
einzuräumen was nicht wetterfest ist
sie hat schon erste erfahrungen mit der
regenzeit sammeln können und weiß wenn
es losgeht dann richtig
monika und ihr partner peter kruse
nutzen die nebensaison und zu
vollbringen was sie schon lange geplant
hatten
seit ihrem ersten rundgang durchs
guesthouse war ihnen klar dass sie die
heruntergekommenen badezimmer renovieren
müssen
acht monate später ist es endlich soweit
6000 dollar kosten die neuen böden und
der umbau der 6b dass wir schweizer nach
wenig tönt ist in kambodscha wo ein
bauarbeiter 60 franken pro monat
verdient sehr viel geld er später das
mit zwei zentimetern und bread butter
spitze ist aber auch frankreich dafür
unter verkehr in der mache ist also nach
der wunschvorstellung
da die platten einfach auf den alten
boden gelegt werden
verliert der raum ein wenig an höhe
deshalb muss die alte türe gekürzt
werden
in der regnerischen jahreszeit kommen
weniger touristen nach sie an und will
dieses brasilianische pfad via internet
für drei tage ein zimmer gebucht
das einzige problem das wir haben wir
bauen gerade alle zähne um 8 uhr früh
beginnen die bauarbeiter ich hoffe das
ist für sie in der zwischenzeit ist
bereits ein weiterer tourist
eingetroffen
im moment ja im moment wo wir haben
bauarbeiten haben einen kleinen rabatt
weil wir alle themen machen und dann
werden dann komm ich mittwoch ja schon
sagst vorbei sind sonst ist dann noch
dass er sich sehr befriedigend dass man
trotz umbauphase
volle sind und immer nachfrage hat und
alles rund um sich für mich ein kreis
und darum gewissen grad eigentlich wo
das meer oder wenn das nierenzentrum
bauen wenn ich könnte dir
[Musik]
während draußen mit dem tanzen die mit
zuckerstangen das mit sommerfest beginnt
ist drinnen der ausgebildete koch rolf
kaiser nicht in festlaune
er wird sich bald ein neues zuhause in
schweden suchen
er bemüht sich der situation etwas
positives abzugewinnen
aber das ist er nicht mittrage
stammkraft sie einfach nicht ganz
stimmen nicht ganz funktioniert
jetzt machen wir schritt weiter sein
das gerät entwickelt aber das ist mit
sicherheit bis zu brauchen
dass das ist mit sicherheit
[Applaus]
zwei traditionen mit sommerfest gehören
auch gruppenspiele erste disziplin
gummistiefel werfen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
vielleicht schneiden die schweizer
besser ab beim nächsten wettkampf den
apfel beißen und raste wartete das ok
und denn herr schwung
[Musik]
auch die erwachsenen schweden haben
keine berührungsängste gegenüber spielen
die sonst eher an kindergeburtstagen
stattfinden
[Musik]
dieses haus ist die erste bleibe eines
kleinen mädchens namens naja schein blum
liebevoll wird sie umsorgt von ihrer
mutter und der großen schwester vater
markus blum macht die videokamera bereit
in einigen jahren wird die kleine nayla
dank filmaufnahmen etwas über ihre
wurzeln erfahren können
im bauch der mutter verbrachte sie zwei
monate in einer blockhütte am
abgelegenen chucky dass sie markus hat
dieses wilde leben im einklang mit der
natur mit seiner eigenen kamera
dokumentiert
das ist dann doch eine spur einschlägen
gesetzt aber es ist am nächsten tag
allerdings ist dieser eigentlich die
familie blum ist die besitzer einer
jagderlaubnis für kleintiere daraus dass
man natürlich auch hier 1000 fische sind
und sich auch selbst dieser marke
sabotiert und dietmar hamann auch in
vielen den vielfraß fahrzeuge harry
wilke auf trab gehalten oder hilfe aus
geldnot lang probiert und es ist ganz
frech mal das ist er hoffe da haben noch
ein bisschen was ist passiert
der hacker mit dem quer musik gehört
aber immer nicht tragen sie sehen aber
es ist immer so
das ist unser weg von dritten sind es am
kloster posa klopfen stück heimat
kelheim erzählt marco sogar
bald werden die bruins wieder an den ort
ihrer erinnerungen zurückkehren
diesmal hoffentlich mit touristen
monika lier hat trifft mit dem
motorroller in guest house ein als co
pilotin mit dabei ein kleines kätzchen
welche sie von den nachbarn bekommen hat
es ist bereits die dritte katze welche
monika bei sich aufgenommen hat
[Musik]
der umbau im gasthaus ist in vollem
gange eine sehr anstrengende
angelegenheit für die arbeiter alles
wird von hand ab gespitzt ohne
maschinelle hilfe denn nicht alles läuft
wie vorgesehen story bald kommen gestern
was mache ich mit der türen
das möchte die hausangestellte sreto
auch gerne wissen
sie versucht bei der hausbesitzerin die
gleich nebenan wohnt nachzufragen
weshalb die türe nicht angetastet werden
darf können die denkt 7 wenn wir den
boden mit zwei spitzen wir ein früherer
kürzlich sei unter dem august
runterstürzen darum sei es gar nicht sie
will das nicht
[Musik]
im gespräch mit einem hausangestellten
der vermieterin lässt sich die sache
schnell lösen
die türe darf gekürzt werden
[Gelächter]
peter hat sich zu schnell aufgeregt
seit drei viertel jahren lebt er nun in
sein okay aber die kambodschanische
gelassenheit scheint ihm noch nicht ins
blut übergegangen zu sein sich davor
etwas wie sich wieder auf platz zwei mit
etwas malen es ist einfach ganz viele
ideen mit
[Musik]
in schweden ist es später als erscheint
hier oben die hohen norden wird es um
diese jahreszeit gar nicht mehr dunkel
[Applaus]
wie ihr seht dem glashaus sitzt möchte
vielleicht endlich mal ruhe vor den
mieten
es ist bereits nach mitternacht als das
fest vorüber ist ganz hessische landtag
sie sich aber extrem spaß gemacht muss
sagen dass das festival oper tätig waren
sind heute hier also eine riesengroße
sache nun so machen und wirklich freut
und sie dankbar und weiße maus ansprache
ich werde auch meine zeiten extrem
kommuniziert und aus aber letztlich wird
es ganz schön eng
[Musik]
daniel macht einen letzten kontrolle
rundgang auf der campinganlage eine
aufgabe die er von seinem früheren beruf
als polizist kennt doch hier auf dem
sand baden kann er alles ein wenig
entspannter angehen
seid nicht zu laut versucht leise zu
sein
[Musik]
prince george ist eine stadt mit 70.000
einwohnern
hier geht amira drei mal pro woche in
die pre school eine freiwillige
vorschule während des vergangenen jahres
hat sie nur selten andere kinder ihres
alters getroffen
[Musik]
die anfängliche scheu am lehrer
mittlerweile abgelegt
[Musik]
mutter sabrina nutzt die freie zeit
[Gelächter]
wie heißt es ist nicht neu nein wir
fahren schon in zwei wochen wieder hoch
zum black jetzt versuchen wir noch alles
rein zu drücken
[Musik]
rick simonson ist nach prince george
gekommen
ihm gehört das campen black lady familie
blumen die meiste zeit des jahres lebt
gemeinsam mit marcus schlette einen
verrosteten tank auf den pick up oben in
bled lake soll der in der diese lagern
den sie für ihren spielen generator
benötigen gerade auf der kante noch ein
paar zentimeter
[Musik]
sabrina und amira kehren aus der stadt
zurück
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die sind auf der anderen seite des
gesichts die familientage in prince
george sind bald vorbei
bereits morgen wird markus mit weg zum
black label fahren
sabrinas land mit den kindern in zwei
wochen nachzukommen
dass ein neugeborenes hinter
abgeschiedenheit mit dabei ist bereitet
uhren in black lake gilt es die kurze
saison vorzubereiten
die blues haben eine erste buchung für
ihre pferde trekkingtour auch fischer
und jäger haben ihr kommen bereits
angekündigt
[Musik]
auf der campinganlage sandbaden der tag
nach dem mit sommerfest für carolin
schneider und daniel schafer gibt es
heute einiges zu tun
vereinzelt machen sich die gäste fertig
zur abreise in der küche bereiten daniel
und carolin das land spiel für den
mittag vor täglich bieten sie drei bis
vier speisen zur auswahl an zu einem
günstigen preis
[Musik]
es ist geld
die auswanderer stehen nun am beginn der
hochsaison
und ausgerechnet jetzt verlässt der
ausgebildete koch rolf kaiser den sand
gegraben
carolin und daniel können es sich nicht
leisten einen anderen koch einzustellen
dafür erwirtschaften sie noch zu geringe
einnahmen
das thema hoffe natürlich dass möglichst
schnell dass man heute wohl aber um
dieses ziel war uns klar dass man so gut
vom sohn jordan holla das völlig neues
geschaffen
daniel die hunde füttern
die sind schließlich auch noch da auf
dem weg zum zwinger sieht der rolf
kaiser hochkommen
[Musik]
es scheint als ob es für die beiden
nicht mehr möglich ist den selben weg zu
teilen und direkt aneinander vorbei zu
gehen
über die schlittenhunde haben daniel und
rolf einst zur freundschaft gefunden nun
gehen sie beim füttern getrennte wege
[Applaus]
die küche wird caroline nach dem abgang
von rolf dauerhaft übernehmen müssen
zusätzlich zur leitung der campinganlage
dem putzen der buchhaltung und der
gästebetreuung trotz der mehrbelastung
haben sich caroline und daniel
entschieden den santschi garten
weiterzuführen
[Musik]
am stück
das bringt dich du kannst
[Musik]
peter kruse schlendert durch den markt
von phnom penh der hauptstadt von
kambodscha
[Musik]
ich stehe draußen am selben platz wie
zuvor beim markt komme ich bitte holen
stock verloren
ich habe doch gesagt du sollst wahl
peter ist nicht nach phnom penh gekommen
um einzukaufen
er erwartet jemanden
da haben ich bin das ich dass ich heute
habe ich einmal die helferin ab oder
dass ich euch sie erst die wohl unter
herrlich offen mit uns reden stütze für
sie sich als salafisten zu entlasten
soll
über die entlastung ist vor allem monika
lehnert phone
sie hatte schon in der schweiz mit ihren
beinen da sie unter einer blutkrankheit
leidet der stress und die ständige
präsenz in guest house haben die sache
mit den beinen noch verschlimmern
bei hochwasser wirklich unschöne schon
bald soll nun hilfe eintreffen
[Musik]
in phnom penh ist peter unterwegs zum
flughafen um seine wohnung theorien
abzuholen
er hat die bündnerin eveline töns dank
eines inserates im internet gefunden
die 22 jährige ist ausgebildete
servicefachangestellte und arbeitete
zuletzt auf dem kühlen grimselpass
die vierstündige fahrt nach dialog will
nehmen sie nicht mit dem talk talk auf
sich sie werden mit dem taxi fahren aber
erst morgen
[Musik]
markus blum ist unterwegs zum lake dem
ort wo er mit seiner familie
mehrheitlich liebt sabrina und die
kinderreisen später nach vor markus wird
rick simonson der besitzer des black
lakes
wenn sie schwer beladene holztransporter
ankündigen ist es besser anzuhalten
als sich der staub gelegt hat ist ein
schwarzbär zu erkennen der sich direkt
neben der straße aufhält
[Musik]
auch das zweite große bild tier kann er
das taucht auf
obwohl schon mitte juni liegt noch
ziemlich viel schnee um an den blick weg
zu gelangen muss seien fast 2000 meter
hoher pass überquert werden
das camp selbst legt dann auf 1300 meter
höhe über 14 stunden hat die fahrt
gedauert
der black lake ist nicht nur lebensort
der familie blumen sondern auch der
ausgangspunkt für die pferde toren die
sie bald durchführen werden so verdienen
sie endlich wieder ein wenig geld denn
auch das einfache leben ist nicht
gänzlich kostenlos
markus richtet die 20 quadratmeter große
holzhütte wieder wohnlich 1
sie wurde nun ein paar monate kaum
benutzt also gefangen hält und dessen
der genaue ort jährigen zulässig
ja das ist jetzt alles noch einmal
gehört
nur fällt jetzt können frauen dass wir
das alles heilen sind
[Gelächter]
in zwei wochen wird markus seine frau
wieder haben
bis dahin ist der black lake noch ein
wenig einsam als sonst
[Musik]
das wiesbaden freut sich über die
unterstützung aus der schweiz
die bündnerin eveline töns ist im
gasthaus eingetroffen
monika zeigt ihn mit stolz wie schön der
umbau geworden ist einfach das machen zu
machen und so schnell in das zimmer 2
sitzplatz gemacht aloe vera und ohne
branche weiter zu dienen
da haben wir vielleicht ganz schmal ist
und daher die luxus-suite
die suite
daher haben wir nachträglich hier machen
dass ist schon idee von mir denn ich
wollte mir tut der hans meistens zu
sehen die ein tag wie nie wie sie
blicken und vorgesehen schwarz sie dass
ich einfach machen wo man daher auf wo
sie in einem pet müssen übernahme der
straße macht sind bei damit diesen peaks
ist ja mal darum musste weil ich genau
der schnitt 10 mio
monika und peter scheinen bei der wahl
ihrer volontärin ein glückliches
händchen gehabt zu haben
mir sind die tränen ausbricht oder was
auch immer für drei monate wird
wiesbaden helfen und so weniger
entlasten
[Musik]
am sand schon sehen hey des dorfes blatt
mixery ist der herbst eingezogen
die stimmung zwischen daniel schafer und
rolf kaiser ist frostig
[Musik]
ganz spezieller tag
rolf hat inzwischen nur wenige kilometer
von santa werden entfernt ein neues
zuhause gefunden
für die vierbeiner hat er bereits eine
zwingeranlage erstellt
[Musik]
nun bringt er seinen neuen
schlittenhunde zu ihrem nächsten
wohnsitz
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein jahr und sechs tage ist es her als
rolf gemeinsam mit daniel und carolin
nach schweden auswanderte nun trennen
sich ihre wege miteinander befreundet zu
sein bedeutet nicht zwangsläufig dass
man auch gut zusammenarbeiten kann
drei der 700 zwinger stehen nur daniel
kocht dann beherrscht für seine hunde ja
es ist natürlich groß für
gesamtsituation musica sacra sogenannte
frühchen muss wieder gold am sinn und
das gibt das geld kam das geld in der
nächsten und letzten folge von auf und
davon verlässt rolf mit familie den
sancho garten endgültig caroline und
daniel genießen ihre neue freiheit
meilenstein in kanada die blues haben
ihre ersten pferde tore mit zahlenden
gästen ein wiedersehen mit der toccata
hütte und die familie kehrt für einen
diavortrag über ihre abenteuer in die
schweiz zurück das gasthaus in
kambodscha läuft immer besser
seit einem jahr haben sie nun geöffnet
zum jubiläum überrascht peter seine
liebste mit einem geschenk
[Musik]
wichtige wege mit alkohol träumen ruf
des urhebers
[Musik]